hello and welcome to our webcast MBA
student insight international students
at the GSB my name is Tom Jeong and I'm
a first year MBA student here at the GSB
I'm joined by my classmate Argent's and
the Michael
Antonin biopsy we'll be talking about
the student experience here at the GSB
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we can to submit a question
to ask about what it's like to be a
student
just click the chat button at the top of
your screen enter the question and click
send to all panelists
please be aware that we won't be able to
talk about emission process the
applications financial aid or the visa
process today you can consult the
website or contact the MVA and emissions
office for that information so let's
begin with introduction where we are
from we were doing before coming to the
GSB and what our goals after the
graduation I'll start so I grew up in
China I came to the States
six years ago to study journalism before
the GSB I was a tech M&A reporter in New
York after the GSB I planned to move
into tech and help suit tech enabled
platforms to help distribution of media
content how about you okay thank you Tom
for the introduction
so my name is my name is Artyom I'm from
I'm from Russia originally most of my
life I lived in Moscow and carry a wise
before before just being I was mainly
he's been in company so I spent more
than four years management consulting
across Europe and also South Africa
office and regarding the poultry eight
beagles I'm two concealing my different
options yes so thank you very much for
introduction as Thomas and I'm from New
Zealand originally I was a professional
rugby player died years before mr. GSB
five of those years in New Zealand and
in the last three in Japan with regard
to what I'm my polish graduation goals
I'm currently exploring a career in the
real estate industry which I'll be doing
an internship of the summer and
hopefully sort of proceeding from there
I
all right so we'll start with some
questions submitted by the audience so
the first question would be do you guys
consider schools outside the US when you
were applying what was your
consideration between US schools and
non-us schools and why did you - I'm
happy to start on this one so at the SA
says right most of my life I spent in
Europe and obviously I consider European
schools as well the way my initiation
process meant
so basically since I spent all of time
in Europe just idea spending some time
in America was more exciting to me
because it was like new geography for me
and also when I thought about the value
of MB I thought what kind of like doors
and being super team today began open
for me and I had a perception that
American MBA it opens some doors in
America but also in Europe and in Asia
it's kind of like global degree while
European and Asian school is still more
kind of like one region focused so from
that kind of like flexibility
perspective American Indian made sense
yeah and I also explored so the MBA
programs enter the u.s. mainly in the UK
focused on Cambridge in Oxford I think
one of the biggest thing that hasn't
touched on a few of them at the global
reach and you know one my network was a
bit more me but also the fact I really
like the the two-year program versus the
one year so the 12-month program reason
for that coming from an untraditional
background I like the idea of you know
it's been my first year exploring
industries
having a summer internship to further
explore led to see whether that is what
I really wanted to do and having a
second year with you could it be posed
up to someone else or the further I
continue down that track so how about
why Stanford yeah I couldn't talk about
my experience so I've been working in
the US before give these all my toys was
supposed mostly focusing that's on US
schools and I know I want to move into
tag and I feel stand for the proximity
to Silicon Valley will be a great space
and also I'm really drawn to the spirit
of personal reflection and comity buting
here at the GSB so that's what's one of
the my
desperation today yeah so uh so for me
it's quite easy question and I think the
answer going to be very similar to what
Tom just said so first of all definitely
broad Silicon Valley to a large extent
is just like very exciting place to live
in
considering Kong how many cool things
are happening wrong and also I was very
fortunate to meet many people from gdb
community even before flying to school
and I just I felt that I clicked with
those people and I felt I felt values
with them this is the idea of spending
two years in the community of this type
of people was very attractive to me yeah
thank you know many of the same points
see that adds that would be one the
class size I really like the fact that
was the size of 400 class this eight
hundred nine hundred and some we are
public schools in the u.s. I thought
that intimacy getting some of your
classmates was a big thing for me second
location in California I mean and the
campus the amazing campus that we have
take one walk around here pretty hard
sort of turn turn away and say that
you'd like to get somewhere else
and then thirdly was just you know the
caliber of students in else going to be
a long time so to be able to come in
from a non-traditional background wanted
to explore different industries I felt
that I would see most of the time to
rates or buzz being around people with
very high caliber exactly yeah
let's see what's the other question so
um how has been the transition to the
u.s. self-education being the Harper you
adjusting from when you used to um yeah
I can start here so I actually studied
abroad in the US and for one semester
back in 2011 so I've had some exposure
to it previously but honestly for me it
wasn't that big of a transition I feel
like I've done sort of higher education
Indian and Australia previously as well
and it was very similar teacher stars
very similar curriculum so it wasn't a
huge transition for me mm-hmm um I would
say for me it was like that difficult as
well so before services academic a
spirit a I said at LSE using monsters
define is there
and I would say that overall the
experience is quite similar the only
thing that surprised me quite a lot is
that I would say like the intensity of
the education at GSB understand that
like if you keep it ever see for example
we have one course that transfer all the
whole year and then we have an exam then
here you have three quarters here in one
academic year and within each quarter
you have the final exam you have the
midterm and you have a lot of group
assignments so like the intensity of the
overall process is something that
surprised me quite a lot but I assume
that's pretty much from where the
experience and the knowledge comes from
I'm just at one point I feel the class
participation where case discussion is
fun something I feel struggled a bit to
adjust physics because coming from an
Asian culture of China you're supposed
to sit there and just answer questions
with your teacher ask you to that way I
feel I need to push myself a little bit
to like raise my hand and jump in yeah
cool so how don't talk about how
welcoming do you feel about the dance
community to it I have to start in this
one so I think first of all like 40% of
people ages be are from international
background which makes between GSB by
definition
I don't welcome international community
because if it's an international
community I also say that G is B has
quite a lot of tools to like to involve
people and to make them part of the
broader community by to swat mu by tools
so like first of all section right the
fact that we start to the first quarter
and be respecting the section 70 people
we get to know quite well over the first
over the first two months of the program
and then you have a squad which becomes
your like inner inner family like seven
people who you know really really well
and also you have co-op activity like
most of the people live on campus so you
bounce into many people and like build
small communities within the residential
area you live in
so not quite a few tools of incorporate
you into the broader community yeah
echoing a lot of those points again I
think in other one campus directly
across the street when we take
Isis I think I'm sort of won a couple of
international students in my wing for
just did that
forced interaction with us students with
other international students which makes
it that's like a welcoming community and
then I'd also say you know the support
staff we have in India office have been
amazing helping a fit woman to talk to
an immigration lawyer putting on
different sort of videos or different
events that if we have any questions
that need to be answered and then again
in the greater Stanford community having
victim international students has been a
great resource so yeah felt very well
doctor
yeah that's great yeah you guys both
mentioned about the social aspect how
about the classroom setting like how do
you think the academics campus
incorporated international experiences
into agreement yes sorry I mean I'm in a
class right now with strategy beyond
markets it's essentially focused on
everything international with room here
one or two classes on the US healthcare
system besides a it's all around sort of
international issues we did a a case
last week
splash mobile networks with maintenance
system in Ghana so I feel that it has
been incorporated in different classes
of new members trying to incorporate at
least a few international cases and just
couple words for my experience my
experience like most of the classes I'm
taking yeah I would say they are
probably like more tilted so totally
like American companies cases but at the
same time I think like most of the cases
they learn they teach there they teach
quite universal lessons which are
clickable to be to the global issues I
wouldn't say that like I personally
considered an English
it's a knowledge awareness yeah yeah
we're talking about the academics maybe
we can also touch up a your favorite
academic experience so far I can start
off so I really love some group projects
but a lot of the classes have to do the
last quarter I took the data and
decision pilot class so we are supposed
to help alumni company and
a regression project so in the whole
order I worked with four other
classmates and like through the whole
our model for me coming from a
journalism background that was a huge
learning experience that I enjoy working
with people working with my classmates
see your project actually helping a
company grow so that's my through
experience about our times do you have
any um I think I enjoy most the classes
that are maybe on the on the number of
guest speakers so in particular like the
two classes on top of my mind would be
like the product launch which is the
advanced marketing class and also be
money-making pause so the the product
launch one we have quite a few interpret
your guest speakers which like every
conversation is them I found being very
title and also the demand in banking
cause they required if you get speakers
from the federal bank so I think that
this elements we have access to the
practitioners from the industry this is
something I've benefited most from yeah
I mean there's a couple classes that
come to mind for me I really enjoyed
organization behavior in the first
quarter Franklin I think is one of the
greatest officials going around and I
loved how just applicable that material
wants to daily interactions with people
I really enjoyed sports business
management class last quarter again
guest speakers amazing GM of the
Warriors owner the San Francisco Giants
you know just like amazing amazing guest
speakers and I think anywhere this would
mean the great things about Stanford
that we have who has that ability and to
bring in them that that type of talent
and then the classes men right now a
real estate investing class would be
given 22 acres in Milpitas just 30
minutes after they're having to put
together like a development plan given
an alumni mentor and so working through
that process like this will real world
applicable skills which I think has been
really amazing
great let's change gear a bit talk about
student activities so talk about your
favorite extracurricular activities so
far I can start off because last Friday
we just had the GSP show and part of the
leadership team I was a stage manager so
a new bit background the Disney show as
a student-run
original musical so we put together the
whole script and the whole production I
was in the Fox Theater we had 1200
people coming it was a great production
I feel super excited to be part of that
I just feel like be in that experience
with your classmate and see the whole
thing put together it is a great
rewarding experience for me ya know just
be sure what this was a big thing and
like weighted by the success like great
job on that one in my experience I would
say that most of the activities
organized by the medic flops ages B's
issues like intrapreneurial co-op - Club
those excuses were really very good and
this is this again like connects to the
the point I made earlier in the guest
speakers because most of those
activities are somehow related to the
people containers coming through Jersey
and also a couple weeks ago we made a
visit to this like office because very
quiet insightful to see how their
mediation works on the inside and also I
can see how amazing facilities we have
here and just being like any course like
swimming pool
why quite a few isn't like not all of
them was like I'm I'm doing my best
right and I think yeah a big one for me
was there two weekends give me a
challenge for charity yeah do you mind
yeah a little bit of background it's
kind of a competition between the
biggest I mean six or seven West Coast
business schools there's a few different
facets of it is sort of volunteer hours
is fundraise money and in Mississippi
and challenge for charity which is held
at Stanford every year and you know just
amazing again sports spelling bees you
know trivia competition what an tell
with work you pay so I did unfortunately
they never rugby so I tried my hand
at American football flag football
Ultimate Frisbee and the cricket I'm not
created from back home but the other two
in American schools and I've I've tried
my hand at but you know OSA on the
cultural side having the Battle of the
Bands having the dance-off on Saturday
night and in a sort of I think it being
a culminating in a social so we can
interact with other business school
students from from the area which is
great to build your network I'm looking
to Korea pose it feels like you two
already integrates into your culture
like pretty like well yeah so will help
us a question on the plant after gypsy
so you plan to go back to your own
country
I'm not only after graduation I also
summer plan I think you touch up how
your plans so sure side uh
so over the summer I'm doing splits I'm
doing a global experience with G max in
Europe for six weeks and then coming
back in doing a weeks in the u.s.
there's a plan iniquity so long I've
never seen a mist inside post TSP I'd
like to spend the US and I think it
makes a lot of sense of the amazing
network that we have here and obviously
we get the one year and what a big deal
now on our student visa
so I'd like to utilize that and then
make a decision from yeah so in my case
I definitely get a go home from June
this summer for this second half of the
summer I plan to be in Bay Area
ending the internship here and then
after graduation is to be decided so
when you are looking for summer work in
teams or thinking about your career
plans and what are the resources from
GSB that offers you as an international
student how do you feel supported by the
career management system here sure I can
say this one stellar
I've been amazing and the CMC for me is
being great and probably so far too much
of me last called oh my gosh I don't
know without having the corporate to the
work experience for pre GSB I was quite
nervous about getting an intern
up but they were great you know they
have a wealth of knowledge of wealth of
context go in you know do some different
activities on the board
find out what you may be passionate
about and industries may be of interest
and they reach out and put in touch you
know you in touch about with CEOs of
companies especially you know they were
great a great resource yeah I was
jumping because there was uncle often
specifically for international student
Bell wallah
so she will organize workshop for all
kinds of work visa and CBT and how can
you stay here in the summer in long run
and also she will pass on opportunities
to specific international students so I
feel personally I got to care of from
the Career Management Center yeah so
also how supportive the student body do
you feel that it's a competitive
environment where do you think is pretty
collaborative how would you describe it
yes I've had this big this one um I
think there's a quite healthy balance of
the competitiveness and the support
didn't leave is energetic community body
competitiveness I think like by design
when you puts in one place for hiring
people with the average amount above
7:30
it's kind of what results in some level
competition but at the same time I think
like the way the admission process to
just be worse mission committee managed
to select people for quite nice and
supportive so at the end of the day it's
quite a healthy for a healthy balance
that can apply which is you and I helps
you develop your personal professional
skills but at the same time its support
different optimal to stress too much
about the process
I feel just be as no one for a likes
pretty friendly were operated
environment I know people self selecting
in a way also if you opt into the GSB
stress so for me I feel really supported
because I feel here
I think Hoffy untouchable we all loops
together on happens across the street so
people treat you as a person as a friend
first up like classmate second or I can
put on all the tax I feel here I can
develop really deep relationships with
all my
I've made a become of really great
friends so that's something I feel is
different where you need to here at the
GSB yeah
so the next trip a question would be is
it common for students at West graduate
school um for their goals to change
during the program for the two years
maybe you can talk about your experience
whether what you were thinking applying
have anything changed yeah yes I think
you know I had an interesting experience
coming in obviously I came in wanting to
explore different industries but I
thought that I was going to go I had
some experience internships investor in
banking sort of mantra financial I was
thinking that I was going to go into
private equity now explore that but you
know once I got here talking people
meeting alumni chatting with classmates
I did change
I sort of pivoted last last corner once
I sort of thought I share we had a
little passion for real estate I met
through classes and classmate so I think
it is very common it's very common for
people to try out a new industry or a
new function of a summer and then
realize that that as a nesting what they
want to do and come back and put push
the reset button and change the track in
their thinking yes I think it is
extremely common yeah exactly yeah I
feel I came into the program really want
to go into pack I want to be a pro no
matter I want to move into a pure attack
company also I feel throughout talking
to people through informational
interviews I realize my true passion is
through in journalism or publishing so I
want to kind of focus on my strengths
not just like trying to learn coding and
everything
but more work on the media product on
their strategy or partnership side so I
can leverage my background so that's
kind of up to them for me so I'm using
that yeah I got I got a couple of words
so I think I think again like this
beauty of two years MBA also helps of
all because like the first year these
people like can stay really open -
resolved any like some time pressure
because it's two years program right and
obviously people are coming from there
grounds and they are exposed to your
ideas constantly and that that quite
often leads to the change of the course
all of the throttle it to your strain
great we've talked a lot about
recruiting and career now I can come
back I think after you mention about max
Frank's lane of the OB professor can you
talk more about like your interaction
with faculty like a there any personal
sorry sir yes which is just overall I
would say that I'm quite impressed by
the level of faculty I'm not only taking
courses the GSB I'm taking quite a lot
of process across the street so I
experienced they the the computer
science department that also think it's
a process from the apartment economics
and now I'm taking a class from the
department's public systems and I would
say like a cross Stanford overall and
she's being particular and quite
impressed with the difficulty level yeah
I agree I think I'm taking touchy-feely
which is another really famous course
here at the GSB on my instructor Gary
Gygax um Gary Dexter and he's really
helpful and Tiant will not only take
care of the content instructor of the
course and he understand read everyone's
journal and have one-on-one interaction
I think the personal attention from the
faculty especially from him is something
I really try to I think is really
palpable here I'll just I'll just
quickly add something sexy I think one
of the amazing things about the GSB one
it is so well there's the balance
between faculties in academics with
integrity and a sort of industry leaders
yeah I think it's a great job of having
whether it's so like teaching a class by
themselves or co-teaching class having
industry leaders you know how to get
super 4-minute Joel Peterson is a big
one that comes to mind to come back and
they come back and they share their
knowledge for us I think that's
something the Stanford UC does so well
so our next question would be with
support and guidance do alumni Hawaii I
think you're both touching on when
you're rich in hell or this given before
gifts about a lot of a month yep
yeah I I guess I never say this one I
think I leverage the network quite a lot
before coming on campus so a condition
this window between me getting the offer
and becoming campus Irish how to fight a
few alums I was quite impressed with the
first like response rate so quite a few
of them were happy to jump on a call or
like meet for a coffee to most my tears
and then I think that helped me to
understand first to understand like both
type of experience I signed up for and
also helping to shape what I want to do
on this one like Apple Jersey and just
the anecdote on this one so a friend of
mine is Roisin to quite a few lumps
through old emails and he told me that
he he feels basically tracking how many
responses he goes inside obstacle above
seventy percent response rate from the
cold emails which i think is quite
impressive like majority of people very
happy to jump on the college team again
to meet for coffee that coffee concerns
that they never met person yeah yeah
danger that is well away pretty much too
so every man when I've seen to alumni
and proceed your response and
interesting willing to turn one phone
call have a chat about anything which is
great yeah tomato another data point I'm
with the Asian business student Club and
we have a mentorship program so I got
assigned to mentors and one of them is
really really helpful in terms of
helping me to learn a job for my summer
internship actually my summer plan is
I'm finding through him hips keep the
reaping investor and he know I'm
passionate about media so he interested
me with the CEO
don't feel not only to just quote email
there are structure program like a
manager programs that the CMC just
rolled out it will help help you build a
long-lasting relationship not just
within the GSB on so your relationships
beyond yeah well so our next question
would be what global experience have you
have well edges Jessie this is free
finding a pair of Uggs we went to the
India global study trip together during
the winter break we had a great skins
there and got to see India
microphone there the people and the
meetings line up with amazing I feel I
got close to a lot of classmates
including you to those South was amazing
yeah don't like so the trip itself I
think that was definitely more my best
weeks and Jays be so far it was quite
quite incredible incredible trick cheap
and this also like brings us to the
point I mentioned earlier on the inner
flight tools within GSB that helps
people to integrate into the community I
think that's a fascinating tool because
like for ten days you traveled across
race and you really have a chance to get
to know them really really well so I can
likely reinforce those very people and
yeah that was that was very fascinating
integration in the again on this jump
call this G max coming up the summer so
I haven't had it yet but it's something
that I'm really looking forward to you
know sexually trip to Europe ESP helps
pay for and makes it a constitution we
know I'm gonna be apprised really
looking forward to that experience
obviously not being in India with you
guys and there's no shortage of trips
you know throughout the academic year
that fellow classmates put together and
you can jump on you know to list ever
but with a group over winter break a
bunch of people were traveling over
spring break so it's definitely no
shortage of great ah
our next question would be what are the
biggest challenges you have faced in
your first year I think I can start off
I think coming from the non-traditional
background also as an international
student I struggle to find my place here
because I feel everyone here is so
accomplished I feel how can I get
approved by my peers and classmates so I
feel there's definitely impossible
syndromes with Emmys oh how did I get
here
so it took me some time to settle in and
I feel I felt overwhelming support from
all my classmates whether they're
internationals were Americans classmate
and I feel I mean it just take time so
after the first quarter after I found
out some rhythm and rejoin my life
batter up batter now I feel like I can
be myself okay
yeah in my experience I would say that
like for me the whole jsb experience is
the large extent is a lesson around the
importance of focus and that was
especially like tough and important
during the first couple of months that
just be it's doing issue but there are
like so many things happening in
parallel and you constantly need to
prioritize there are so many persons to
answer to like what classes you
prioritize like what type of communities
lead you to be your prioritized how
you're probably sure Korea Assyrians are
like silly question to answer and I
think that was especially difficult
during the first quarter yeah I didn't
care that as well I think coming from
England not so heavy not sit in a
classroom for a long time when I started
I like you know drinking from the files
or not with them and obviously with the
court system here you know it is
extremely dynamic teen weeks 670 classes
attractive 18 weeks for me it was really
just getting into the small things and
like you guys have touched on some
balancing on the imposter syndrome which
I think everybody has to some degree
have us to all of the other activities
and running in parallel it really come
into a realization that you don't need
to do the every single one of them so I
think just see I getting that balance of
the work learn with your social life and
also taking some time to just chill out
and say to yourself okay so we're almost
out of time today but before I go
argaman Hoffy any final words of advice
for international students thinking
about applying to Denver for NBA maybe
I'm couple words uh yeah okay sure a
couple words to my side I would probably
say that as all of us mentioned it's a
large extent about the community and I
would suggest to spend some time like
that in the community emulate meet
people from Jersey we can approach and
just like try to understand for yourself
whether this is the people you want to
be wrong for the next two years
real life and even answered yes like on
this live live because it's a
fascinating place to be yeah I think for
me it would just be making sure that you
have the best possible application for
yourself prepared before you apply I
think you know whether there's GMAT
whether that's talking to current
students reaching out around your essays
and how to shave them doing research
pieces I just think make sure that
you're really putting your best foot
forward as for me my advice would be
just be yourself be authentic
I think only you know where you truly
passion about only do know what kind of
story you can tell you that you are
unique as a person so don't be afraid
these different coming down traditional
backgrounds not a problem international
student also will be proud of yourself
okay great so now we'll wrap up thank
you both for joining us and thank you
for everyone in the audience for
participating you can learn more about
the MBA program and the emission process
on the GSB website the application for
the next application cycle will be
available in June
thanks again and have a great day